[Musique]
personne n'oubliera cette année 2020
lorsque l'épidémie est arrivée la
pandémie a démarré nous étions un peu
tous comme la poule devant son couteau
mon premier sentiment c'est de venir de
toute façon ça va durer 15 jours nous
sommes en guerre en guerre sanitaire
serre et cela requiert notre
mobilisation générale
est-ce qu'on était en guerre non je
crois que ce mot là ne convient pas du
tout à la situation la guerre contre un
virus avec lequel on peut pas négocier
un depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
ils sont en première ligne à pied
d'oeuvre pour faire appliquer les
nouvelles règles d'une époque incertaine
les maires de france on voyait bien
monter le nombre de cas la peur et la
rejetions face à la crise la plus
violente que notre génération est connue
donc on a été confrontés à des
situations humainement très très dure
une vingtaine de décès dans la première
vague de l'épidémie chez nos agents
ville de paris
pris de court par une pandémie sans
précédent l'état navigue à vue
expérimente corrige entraînant avec lui
ses élus de terrain certains moments
comme vous j'ai appris
à la radio à la télé ce qui allait se
passer les jours d'après nous avons
probablement eu des doctrines trop
changeantes trop fluctuante il ya eu un
moment où il fallait un gps pour savoir
dans quelles rues fallait porter un
masque à préfailles et le porter partout
ce genre d'incertitude alors à l'échelon
local on active ses ressources
on re découvre le système d on coordonne
les réseaux de solidarité
on prépare la résilience on perçoit très
vite ce que va être une forme de rôle
intermédiaire entre
décision et puis le fait qu'il faut que
ça se mette en place très concrètement
sur un territoire
un an après le début de la crise
sanitaire
nous avons suivi cette mère dans leur
combat contre la copie de 19 de la
capitale parisienne à la ville
industrielle de rouen en passant par
nancy deuxième site et étudiants du pays
ou encore l'union nouvellement
écologique
après une année 2009 difficile les
maires de ces villes font désormais face
à une campagne de vaccination poussive
et aux dégâts sociaux économiques de
plusieurs mois de restrictions
[Musique]
marie régissent ce matin à lyon
l'ambiance semble décontracté et
pourtant comme chaque jeudi
c'est l'heure de la cellule de crise
depuis un an
c'est un rendez vous incontournable pour
grégory douce et autour de la table
c'est adjoint à la santé lui faut un
état des lieux de la pandémie
en novembre dernier la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie fut dévastatrice pour sa
ville alors chaque rapport est source
d'angoissé même pour le maire de lyon
qui au cours de sa carrière dans
l'humanitaire à gérer des crises
épidémie comme et vollard en afrique de
l'ouest
en ce début de campagne de vaccination
une inquiétude que partage tous les
maires de france où sont les vaccins
qu'est ce qu'une information on a
aujourd'hui sur les livraisons mais
parce que directeur dhl nordic hardware
est ce que disait que lui on avait très
peu il ya une semaine et qu'il en aurait
justement d'ici deux semaines sur la
visibilité donnée à plus long terme
interrogés les jours on a dit on n'a pas
d'informations nouvelles à ce jour et
après c'était deux montées parti avec 1
février
céline juste une question est ce que le
alors que le rire est toujours élevé le
fait que le taux de positivité des c'est
ce que ça pourrait être lié à un plus
grand nombre de tests effectués sur
[Musique]
comme souvent depuis le début de cette
crise l'élu local se heurte à une
pénurie d'informations mais il faut
rester dans l'action alors pour
compenser la lenteur d'une situation sur
laquelle il n'a pas la main grégory
doucet met l'accent sur le dépistage
[Musique]
quelques quelques jours en conseil
municipal
certains d'élus d'opposition nous
interpellait sur notre politique de
dépistage en disant qu est ce que la
ville fait beaucoup à la ville n'a pas
participé à la grande campagne menée par
la région auvergne rhône-alpes
pathétique pas je leur ai répondu mais
la ville elle fait du dépistage depuis
le depuis mois de septembre n'a pas
attendu que un autre acteur se mettent à
se bouger pour pour faire du dépistage
même la maire du 9e arrondissement de
lyon est présent pour montrer l'exemple
après que
à côté de chez moi
r très rapidement
ce centre de dépistage éphémère a été
installé dans le quartier de la duchère
à lyon
l'objectif est d'aller vers les publics
les plus isolées de ce quartier
prioritaire mal desservies par les
laboratoires en venant ici chacun la
possibilité de aussi de poser des
questions rencontrer des professionnels
bien sûr se faire tester c'est la
priorité
je vais pas m'en vais vous présenter
marisa retour du corps ni l'attrition la
ville de lyon on sentait mal et ça j'y
vois là donc du coup monde on a mis en
place du coup plusieurs dispositifs
oui voilà deux des coûte donc du coup
bah on propose voilà on adapte un peu en
fonction
et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont montre la
marisela de ce matin on a des questions
de santé mentale de gens qui voient là
ça commence à montrer ça commence à être
pesant il de fermat les quartiers
prioritaires ce sera intéressant
justement tirer un bilan après les deux
opérations les deux fois deux jours
justement de la présence de ces points
info santé pour voir si il faut pas
identifié d'autres opportunités
d'autres lieux pour pouvoir les
répliquer
[Musique]
tant que journaliste vous faites aussi
la diffusion d'informations sanitaires
beaucoup de gens sont informés mais on
se rend compte qu'il ya un certain
nombre de publics de personnes qui
malgré tout passe à côté des canaux
d'information démontrer l'importance de
la poursuite du dépistage certes la
campagne de vaccination a débuté
donc je pense qu'il n'a échappé à
personne maintenant qu'elle se fait à un
rythme on va dire
ouah à pic voilà exactement à rouen
le maire est prête à mobiliser son plus
grand stade mais le problème est
ailleurs
[Musique]
je sais pas si philippe et là je mets
faire peut-être un petit point quand
même sur sur la partie vaccins et
centres de vaccination intercommunale et
c'est philippe tu peux tu peux ne sait
pour quelle date avril 1,6 à rouen la
mobilisation bénévole allez plutôt
marché sylvain mais honnêtement
honnêtement le kin d'arena est quand
même nettement plus facile d'accès que
la halle aux toiles
il va y avoir plus de vaccins
globalement qui devrait arriver en
devrait donc pouvoir augmenter la
capacité à vacciner par jour et que ça
on va aussi étendre les plages de
deux personnes éligibles quoi la
vaccination enfin l'état donc tout ça
mérite quand même pour un gros centre
enfin bref qu'on dit depuis le début
c'est mieux vaut tard que jamais en
effet en décembre dernier si la campagne
de vaccination est annoncée en grande
pompe l'été elles semblent privilégier
la vaccination de proximité
j'ai déjà demandé aux élus d'identifier
des structures dans lesquelles nous
pourrions travailler avec eux pour y
rassembler des médecins des infirmières
je ne suis pas du tout certain que ça
doivent prendre c'est mon opinion
la forme de grands stades dans lesquels
viendrait faire la queue des milliers de
personnes en plein hiver une crainte
vite démentie dans la réalité le palais
des sports de gerland à lyon est l'un
des premiers stades à ouvrir ses portes
pour la vaccination
un espace colossal organisé et néanmoins
désespérément inexploité ici entre
février et mars 2021
on vaccine moins de 300 personnes par
jour faute de doses suffisantes
la france a désigné très très tard le
responsable de la vaccination et ensuite
à reste à désigner un responsable en
l'occurrence une responsable logistique
15 jours ou trois semaines après le
lancement officiel de la campagne de
vaccination morissette avait déjà été
vaccinés depuis un certain temps la
réponse qui a été faite au maire qui
avait
et est proactif et anticipe et la
nécessité de faire des centres de
vaccination des vaccins d'europe vous la
connaissez si elles étaient négatives où
je dois avouer que on ne comprenait pas
bien cette position
puisqu'on savait pertinemment qu'il
fallait aller vite
à force d'être précautionneux on oublie
d'être efficace après trois mois de
flottement le maire de cannes a décidé
de passer à la vitesse supérieure
quitte à engager un véritable bras de
fer avec l'état
[Musique]
le 25 mars dernier défiant le calendrier
du gouvernement david lisnard à nous
dans sa ville l'ouverture à la
vaccination plus de 50 e merci nous
avons gardé depuis qu'on a lancé
l'ouverture élargi aux 50 ans et plus
nous avons rentré 5000 nouveaux rendez
vous depuis le 24 mars
répartis à peu près entre eux 2500 sur
la tranche d'âge 65 74 et 2500 sur la
tranche d'âge 50 64 donc on va bien que
y'en a qui n'est pas encore inscrit dans
la tranche d'âge et qui bouche à oreille
aussi qui se fait j'en vois ça se passe
très bien et donc
tradition dérive alors qu'ils n'avaient
pas nécessairement envie de faire au
départ et serait quand même incongru de
ralentir les établissements qu'ils
soient qu'ils vaccinent vite pour
favoriser ceux qui vaccinent moins vite
ce serait une forme d'égalitarisme de
nivellement par le bas qui serait
absolument incongru donc il faut sortir
de cette philosophie on respecte les
doses qui nous sont attribués on
comprend pas des doses à d'autres et
comme en optimisant encore bien on a
aussi ouvert la vaccination enseignants
et cinq étages du corps habilité et aux
forces de l'ordre
on apprend on a fait ce qu'on devait
faire on a continué j'ai expliqué très
clairement représentant de l'état qu'il
soit préfet ou rs comment en pratique et
aujourd'hui il ya enfin nous il n'y a
pas de polémique prendre
les équipes probables on a anticipé on a
commencé à accumuler avant et ensuite
dès le départ il n'y a pas une bosse de
perdus comme on avait créé cette cellule
de suivi de qu'ovide privé public depuis
février 2020 on a travaillé tout de
suite avec la ceppm avec on a réuni des
professionnels et on était prêt on a
envoyé un plan de vaccination par écrit
alors fait par là le 4 décembre j'avais
écrit au préfet à l'aise
donc il y avait les praticiens le
parcours l'expérience et les compétences
c'est ce qui a permis d'être de gagner
du temps et d'aller la voir la france un
pragmatisme et une force logistique qui
ont permis aux maires d'être
opérationnels et ce dès le début de la
crise quand j'ai vu la progression de la
mortalité dans un certain nombre des
pannes
très vite je me suis dit qu'une des
façons de contenir cela c'était à la
fois de tester les personnels et y
compris les non symptomatiques alors que
la doctrine de l'état était qu'on ne
testait les gens que s'ils étaient
symptomatiques je me suis heurté à un
mur quand même un de bureaucratie et à
un moment donné j'ai dit stop ça suffit
je le fais quand même et puis finalement
ça a servi puisque faire quand même ces
tests là ça a permis de généraliser
cette pratique là et mon rôle n'est pas
de respecter une doctrine si elle ne
protège pas donc c'est un sac servait
territoire nous saisir des enjeux
pactiv des solutions locales adaptées
avec les outils qui sont les nôtres il a
fallu prendre ses responsabilités là qui
en fait ne relève pas de dmr mais on l'a
fait on a géré par exemple des questions
relatives aux masques
puisque face à l'impréparation du pays
il a fallu qu'on se retrouve tous les
manches on a innové
on a créé des ateliers de confection de
masques dans toutes nos mairies dans
beaucoup de lieux
on s'est mis à travailler sur des formes
qui était totalement inhabituel beaucoup
plus agile et pour cause la résilience
locale a montré toute sa plus-value ces
derniers mois cet après midi le maire de
nancy rend visite à daouda vie dans son
nouvel atelier textile il y a un an
la crise sanitaire les avait réunis pour
une aventure mouvementée en avril 2020
lorsque la france entière recherche des
masques mathieu klein le sollicite en
urgence bouleversant ses chaînes de
production
il lui confie la mission de fabriquer
des masques pour l'intégralité de la
population de meurthe et moselle en deux
mois j'avais un peu les euros et je me
suis dit comment tout ça ça va être
fallait être possible et là c'est à ce
moment là que donc sébastien m'a dit
tout simplement l' écoute d'une mousse
ce dont on a besoin
et puis on se met à son service et puis
on y va on a développé des lignes en
fait en l'espace de deux semaines à
peine donc commandé on a commencé
exactement à fabriquer des masques on
appellerait toujours le 2 mai à 6 heures
du matin et ça s'est terminé le 11
juillet en finalité on a fabriqué 850
mille masques avec un pic de production
à 19 19 mille pièces sur 24 heures avec
cinq équipes qui tournait 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24
les débuts ont été forcément très
difficile
beaucoup de pression c'est une grosse
attente de tous les maires du
département
j'adore envie que leurs administrés et
puisse avoir ses masques la la sortie à
la sortie la sortie du premier
confinement très vite se pose la
question du personnel pour relever le
défi
on embauche 75 employés en insertion
professionnelle s'est relativement bien
passé même avec un public en insertion
parfois des personnes qui me disait je
n'ai pas travaillé pendant dix ans et
voilà faire un bout de chemin avec eux
on en a d'ailleurs des personnes qui
étaient dans ces masques ont aidé à
garder ici et d'ailleurs on va continuer
à embaucher
et c'est vrai que ça a été une aventure
humaine incroyable
loin des idées reçues sur l'inertie du
service public cette collaboration a
prouvé la réactivité des municipalités
en temps de crise
revenu dans le système normal avec des
bancs des financements etc
ça prend tout de suite beaucoup plus de
temps là où à l'époque je passais un
coup de filet en 48 heures s'était réglé
aujourd'hui ça prend une semaine dix
jours et c'est ça et surtout en fait ça
démontre bien que lorsque demande à
l'administration du travail est entre
guillemets avec des privés
l'attitude une agilité qui s'opèrent
quand toutes les parties veulent
travailler ensemble et c'est vrai que là
moi le maître mot je pense de cette de
cet effort de cet effort combiné c'est
vraiment l'agilité qu'on va retrouver au
sein d et son agilité qui est possible
et orchestré et de deux pour nous en
tout cas d'une usine de magna
c'est le système d c'est le système d on
fait avec les moyens du bord
les solutions existent parce que c'est
vrai que cette agilité cette réactivité
cette connaissance du terrain à
proximité elle est là donc il faut s'en
servir faut s'en servir pour faire
avancer des solutions
un an après l'épidémie progresse
toujours forçant le gouvernement à
prendre de nouvelles mesures
la situation sanitaire de notre pays
s'est dégradée au cours des derniers
jours c'est pourquoi notre choix de le
pas confinée à une contrepartie
j'ai demandé aux préfets des
départements concernés d'engager des
concertations avec les élus et
d'envisager dans tout ou partie de ce
territoire des mesures de freinage
proches de celles mises en place à nice
et d'un choeur un an si les chiffres ne
sont pas bons et la ville se retrouve en
vigilance surveillée au lendemain des
annonces comme demandé le maire est en
réunion avec le préfet jean viendra non
plus à 18 heures ces annonces place 20
départements en situation de
surveillance renforcée quelqu'un de la
mer de moselle avec comme vous l'avez eu
de fortes disparités entre le su les
élus
merci merci monsieur le préfet bonjour à
toutes et à tous dès lors que le
gouvernement décide de deux qualifiés 20
départements français de surveillance
renforcée cela doit nécessairement
conduire à la mise à disposition de
moyens nouveaux
il n'est pas possible de continuer avec
des moyens équivalents aux similaires à
ceux de territoires qui sont moins
concernés vous donne un seul chiffre qui
est assez éclairant les verbalisations
pour non respect du couvre-feu avant les
beaux jours était de 25%
elle est aujourd'hui de 70% depuis les
premiers retours de premières
températures plus clémentes donc nous
aurons besoin de moyens
en terre pour veiller à ce que dans
l'espace public notamment je le dis nous
avions demandé nous fin juillet le
retour du port du masque obligatoire
dans le centre ville donc à l'habitude
du port du masque aujourd'hui quand même
relativement respectés mais par contre
sur le respect du couvre feu les choses
vont aller en se complexifiant dans les
jours et les semaines qui viennent
tester alerte et protéger les mesures
renforcées coûte de l'argent et depuis
un an les finances des municipalités
sont mises à rude épreuve
le quoi qu'il en coûte n'est pas
autorisée aux collectivités locales
je rappelle que les collectivités
territoriales mairie ou au train
l'obligation de voter un budget sans
déficit contrairement à l'état qui a dû
jamais voté un budget tels que soient
les gouvernements sans déficit depuis 30
ans 40 ans nous on en a l'obligation
c'est même pas une question de débat
politique c'est une obligation légale
c'est vrai que l'année 2020 a été très
particulière pour nos finances locales
l'année 2021 s'annonce aussi extrêmement
compliqué quand vous vous retrouvez avec
tous les restaurants avec tout le
secteur de l'hôtellerie tout le secteur
du tourisme qui est en panne sèche plus
également la culture l'événementiel dans
une ville comme paris ça fait beaucoup
de recettes en moins pour la ville pour
une ville comme la nôtre c'est pour
l'année 2020 et 800 millions d'euros
entre les dépenses et les noms recettes
nos personnels continuent à travailler
parce que nous n'avons pas bénéficié du
dispositif de chômage partiel n'a même
pas été spécialement accompagné par
l'état sur 7 sur cet aspect là les
centres de vaccination aujourd'hui ils
fonctionnent très concrètement avec des
moyens municipaux que ce soit en
personnel en logistique et ça représente
des coûts importants
confinement déconfinement couvre-feu
alors même que les recettes s'effondrent
chaque mesure de protection sanitaire
induit une logistique lourde avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours les faire
appliquer dans une grande ville relève
du défi
à rennes ce matin on tente d'abord de
comprendre la règle et ça donne parfois
lieu à des situations cocasses
au coeur du débat comment faire pour
éviter les regroupements au marché des
lices et ce n'est pas gagné et l'élixir
et du coup il sort deux nouveaux juges
ont des jeux des cages et à en compter
que les gens consommaient au soldat ce
saint maxent d'ascq il semble que
l'arrêté comme prix ne permet pas de
limites et donc il faudrait qu'on prenne
un arrêté
nadal était beaucoup plus ils permettent
la verbalisation pas la verbalisation
peut semer au moins une sensibilisation
à l'art que donc une commerçante qui
fonde avant de raconter tout ça comment
présenter pour être consommé une cabine
extérieure du marché
évidemment voir interdire la vente à
emporter pour l'e commerce le déficit
qui sont pas dans ce périmètre du marché
n'est pas forcément maison d'arrêt de
beausoleil samedi
pour lundi c'est subtil du lundi pour
l'être sur la façon dont vous faire
passer le message
dottori de la caf et non c'est ça on ose
on continuerait à autoriser la vente par
contre on interdirait la consommation
sur le périmètre du marché
ces badges leurs jours ben le nom
visiblement mieux
donc il faudrait que l'arrêté soit clair
sur le fait que la consommation sur
place et d'internet
la communication a été vraiment quelque
chose de fondamental notamment dans la
réinterprétation des messages nationaux
qui pouvait parfois être un peu confus
ou ambiguës sur qu'est-ce qu'on a le
droit de faire dans les parcs et jardins
les marchés comment ça fonctionne et
c'est vrai qu'il nous a fallu beaucoup
communiquer dans cette période madame
monsieur ce vendredi 20 mars
nous sommes au quatrième jour du
confinement décidées par le gouvernement
n'y a jamais eu autant de petites vidéos
ou capsules de deux mères s'exprimant
directement auprès d'eux
des habitants du territoire et surtout
jamais autant du sur ces petites vidéos
qui donnait quelques informations
concrètes à aujourd'hui sur le mois
d'avril le mois d'avril
il est en particulier sur les premières
semaines d'avril il est attendu
l'augmentation d'un tracteur environ 2
c'est-à-dire plus 100 % soit de quoi du
vaccin gardé des liens avec chacune et
chacun d'entre vous dans le contexte
sanitaire que nous connaissons et dont
on désespère un peu de savoir quand il
se terminera pour qu'on puisse retrouver
une vie normale avec en particulier
m
garder le lien permet aux maires de
détecter en amont les dommages
collatéraux de la crise ce qu'on ne
mesure pas avec des statistiques car
l'état ne peut pas tout anticiper les
édiles de terrain agissent comme des
sentinelles de leur territoire j'ai pris
la décision de faire des permanences
sans rendez vous ce qui n'existe pas à
ma connaissance dans aucune ville de
plus de 100000 habitants et vous voyez
plein de situations il ya une situation
qui revient c'est des personnes seules
mais qu'est ce que vous faites contre la
solitude va pas faire une loi pour
interdire aux gens des deux seules et là
dessus arrive le coc vide et arrive le
confinement donc effectivement on s'est
dit qu'il fallait qu'on accélère sur ces
sujets au centre local d'information et
de coordination danger le clic
c'est ce que tente de faire les employés
main dans la main avec les services de
la mairie
les coordinateurs sont débordés par les
sollicitations de personnes isolées et
ceux qui se manifestent ne sont que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg
le vrai défi c'est de repérer les autres
ce qu'on ne voit pas beaucoup plus
nombreux plus de solitude puisque c'est
dans un plan daide calibré financer la
personne a un salaire en contrepartie de
sa présence d'abord on a commencé par
prendre votre fichier le plan canicule
on s'est dit même s'il fait pas chaud
globalement toutes les personnes dont
nous avons connaissance et qui se sont
signalés parce qu'elles sont isolés et
que en cas de canicule il est
souhaitable d'aller les chercher façon
assez inattendue ça nous a permis
d'avoir finalement une sorte de liste
des personnes a priori fragile où seul
et la période n'est pas terminée et on
continue et on voit bien qu'il ya encore
des choses à faire
cet élan là qui fait quand même partie
des choses positives la question c'est
effectivement comment on le prolonge
et toujours dit d'autre qu' on
n'atteignait pas le coeur de cible c'est
bien que les gens véritablement et celui
qu'on n'arrive pas à les années ont été
extrêmement rares à se faire inscrire je
vous rappelle rien et donne dans le
grand ouest sur l'ouverture du centre de
vaccination avec ses deux anciens de 91
et 92 ans qui disait ne pas être sortis
de chez eux qui vont installer revers
assez c'est assez c'est assez sur elle
ça pourrait aussi l'occasion de la
vaccination du passage au centre de
vaccination pour être l'occasion vis et
nous nos coordonnées parce que là en fin
de compte les premiers les plus fragiles
ils sont là par exemple elle prend tout
cela mais je suis persuadé que qui passe
c'est une très bonne idée
c'est vraiment une très bonne idée
région il faut qu'on regarde comment on
peut mettre ça en place
est-ce que vous avez des questions c'est
super j'ai ri donné le coup d'envoi
parce que en plus c'est pour la bonne
cause donc tout va bien
et rassurez vous je ne sais pas ce que
j'ai mais il est probable que dans
quelques minutes le monsieur qui est à
ma gauche mais qui fait que je suis en
retard pendant bon courage à vous on a
vraiment dire si le plan de lutte contre
l' isolement a été créé pour aider les
personnes âgées
la crise a vu naître de nouvelles
victimes de la solitude comme base
initiale de 2000 c'était quand même
plutôt des personnes âgées
c'est ça n'était plus sur des profils
plus de 70 à 75 ans et là on constate
que depuis le mois de janvier on
continue à voir
la selle et on n'est pas sur des profils
qui sont moins engagés est de plus en
plus du profil et le type étudiants ou
jeunes professionnels citoyens le maire
s'est pas vraiment une double casquette
la double casquette ces mères et pères
cessé d'avoir des enfants qui ont 21 19
et 16 vous êtes en plein milieu de tous
les sujets de cette génération qui se
retrouve un âge où elle devrait pouvoir
faire preuve d'insouciance confronté à
un brouillard sur l'avenir sur les
conditions dans lesquelles des examens
vont se passer sur la la possibilité de
faire des stages de s'insérer dans la
vie active ou tout simplement de pouvoir
passer des moments avec des amis au
moment où c'est structurant pour sa
personnalité et donc je suis soucieux de
de l'héritage que nous faisons à cette
jeune génération
je prétends pas que ce soit facile de
faire autrement
je dis juste que il va falloir qu'on
soit hyper attentif à ce que ça donne
l'autre à ce que ça peut laisser plus
que tout autre les jeunes de la
génération qu'ovide garderont en mémoire
cette solitude celle qui a remplacé ce
qui devait être des années de liesse
autour d'une table de restaurant dans
une salle de concert au comptoir d'un
bar animé
oui bien sûr qu'il faut des
consultations si pour les étudiants bien
sûr mais laissons les allées dans les
musées laissons les allées au cinéma
la culture c'est à la fois ceux dont on
se nourrit mais c'est aussi ce que l'on
partage par les ensembles de de l'oeuvre
qu'on a vu au musée du dernier film
qu'on a vu c'est créer du lien aussi
entre nous confronter nos avis nos
expériences
la culture c'est ça aussi c'est cette
richesse qui se créent aussi dans les
changes
l'épanouissement l'émancipation aussi
finalement je pense je vais le dire de
manière un peu grossière mais je pense
que un bon film ou une bonne exposition
peut largement remplacé une séance chez
un psy ravagée par les dommages
collatéraux d'un état d'urgence
indéfinie les jeunes générations se
heurte désormais à la violence de la
précarité
une violence qui ne se comptent pas
encore en chiffres impalpable insidieuse
mais grandissante et une nouvelle charge
sur les épaules des municipalités
non
[Musique]
il faut aujourd'hui une aide d'urgence
dans la crise parce qu'aujourd'hui les
jeunes s'appauvrissent malheureusement
en raison des conséquences de la crise
sanitaire et face à ça il n'y a aucune
réponse
on nous répond que toute aide financière
serait en fait une incitation à
l'assistanat
je ne crois pas que des jeunes aient
envie de rentrer dans la vie par de
l'assistanat
ils ont envie de conduire leur projet
ils sont très impliqués sur les
questions de solidarité sur les
questions de climat
ils ont plein d'idées à la tête de la
deuxième ville étudiante du pays
le maire de nancy est aussi un militant
depuis ses jeunes années depuis toujours
son aventure politique se motive autour
des questions sociales
aujourd'hui il se rend au secours
populaire
l'unef y organise une récolte
alimentaire pour les étudiants la visite
du maire est l'occasion pour le syndicat
de faire remonter les obstacles qu'ils
affrontent et vous stockez sattouf ou
alors le reste du temps vos problèmes
peut y accéder à coups de pioches pour y
entreposer leurs encore possible
on est obligé de se répartir dans les
apartés assez compliqué ce convoi nous
pour vous aider pour l'instant j'en
parlerai à charge pour qu'ils voient un
peu si on peut retrouver un vieux
éventuellement c'est malheureusement une
triste illustration de cette crise de se
rendre compte qu aujourd'hui pour se
nourrir tout simplement des étudiants
qui ne sont pas forcément des étudiants
en situation de pauvreté
il y a encore un an sont aujourd'hui
tenues un certain moment de franchir la
porte d'une association caritative ou de
solliciter de l'aide pour pouvoir
acheter des produits d'hygiène de
première nécessité ou s'alimenter et
d'ailleurs la métropole du grand dansiez
la ville de nancy ont renforcé depuis le
début de la crise leur soutien
opérationnel financier aux associations
caritatives aux associations étudiantes
pour qu'elle puisse accompagner celles
et ceux qui constituent aujourd'hui
malheureusement de nouveau bénéficiaire
pour les distributions alimentaires
si la fonction de maire impose de
trouver des solutions au fur et à mesure
que des problèmes se posent il est des
symptômes de la pandémie qui ne trouvent
pas de réponse lakovic 19 entraîne dans
son sillage les enjeux qui dépassent
largement les conséquences sanitaires
la crise voit s'accumuler les égoïsmes
les colères les en patience il n'y a pas
à un moment spécifique mais c'est un
ensemble de mouvements qui sont des
moments de de frustration de tristesse
et de colère humaine sur un sujet dont
on parle peut-être pas suffisamment ce
que je veux dire c'est le regain de
violence pour des raisons qu'on ne peut
pas justifié mais qu'on peut expliquer
qu'ils sont liés au confinement qui sont
liés à des problèmes de précarité à aux
conséquences économiques et sociales en
fait de la situation sanitaire et que
vous n'êtes pas forcément outillés au
niveau de la mairie vous ça fait des
années qu'on réclame des moyens
supplémentaires notamment en matière de
police nationale et on les a toujours
pas et ça c'est la chose la plus la plus
difficile
il n'y a pas de d'indicateurs de ses
agacements de ces de ces difficultés de
ces tensions mais elles sont là je je
les vois dans mes permanence sans rendez
vous je les vois dans les contacts avec
les gens je les vois dans l'agressivité
d'une partie des usagers qui vont exiger
une réponse de manière beaucoup plus
rapide puis je la vois tout simplement
dans dans le niveau de tension qui est
aussi créée par cette crise sanitaire
entre des gens qui écrivent pour dire
c'est scandaleux au nom du sanitaire on
est en train de tuer toute l'économie et
des gens qui m'envoient des photos à
18h15 au pied de leur immeuble en disant
comment se fait-il que le couvre-feu
soit pas respectée envoyé la police pour
verbaliser ce groupe de jeunes je suis
inquiète tu moment où à un moment vous
des confiné et vous mettez tous ces gens
là les uns en face des autres
quant au printemps vous pourrez sortir
de chez vous uniquement pour travailler
vous rendre à un rendez vous médical
pour porter assistance à un proche pour
faire vos courses essentielles ou
prendre l'air à proximité de votre
domicile
les commerces qui ont été définies au
printemps comme non essentiels les
établissements recevant du public
notamment les bars et restaurants seront
fermés témoin de la grande bouffe 90 qui
gagnent leurs habitants les maires
redoutent la montée en puissance des
tensions al'annonce du deuxième
confinement ils sont nombreux à être
montés au créneau
la démocratie aussi doit venir des
territoires et des choses ne peuvent pas
être imposés comme ça administrativement
par le gouvernement les décisions des
plus dur c'est quand vous devez
appliquer des décisions dont vous ne
partez à la pertinence 1 comment
vous demande d'aller faire fermer des
magasins alors que l'on pense que ça n'a
pas de sens économique et sanitaire
on a du mal à la faire appliquer la
liste des arrêtés municipaux s'allonge
aussitôt déboutée par les préfets je
prenne un arrêté pour que les commerces
notamment de vêtements chaussures
produits de beauté web puisse vendre
j'ai eu un retour la préfecture ce matin
qui m'a demandé de retirer l'arrêté
j'ai dit je leur tire est pas donc ils
m'ont dit gré
faire encore un ex ministre at il
[Musique]
si certains maires s'opposent
frontalement d'autres essaye d'adapter
les textes aux réalités de leur
territoire à cannes les commerçants
peuvent vendre sur leur pas-de-porte ce
que j'ai rappelé aussi au préfet qu'il a
accompli jeudi vous n'êtes pas le préfet
amazon sire que la règle il suffit de
regarder les textes autorisent le click
and collect comme les commerçants ne
pouvait pas ouvrir leur magasin n'est
pas le droit d'accueillir dans leur
magasin ceux qui n'ont pas des réseaux
de distribution qui la mène et non à une
majorité des commerçants de quartier
si je ne l'avais pas autorisés à
utiliser en l'occurrence gratuitement
l'espace public devant leur pas de porte
je crée je cautionnais une distorsion de
concurrence
absolument injuste donc j'ai pas créer
un droit
j'ai juste veiller à ce qu'à cannes le
droit soit appliqué qu'on soutienne de
commerçants le tourisme est le poumon
économique de cannes pour sauver le
secteur
le maire et ses équipes travaillent déjà
à la préparation du monde posco vide
l'enjeu pour nous et ça fait un an que
je plaide cela et que l'on a on a
beaucoup travaillé c'est de montrer que
même en période d'épidémie qu'ovide on
peut tenir des activités touristiques
on peut accueillir du monde de façon
extrêmement sécurisé sur le plan
sanitaire
c'est ce que l'on fait à cannes avec cet
accompagnement des socioprofessionnels
pour les adapter à la nouvelle donne aux
nouveaux marchés aux nouvelles attentes
des consommateurs
aujourd'hui il a réuni les acteurs
socioprofessionnels du tourisme les
syndicats hôteliers et restaurateurs
le directeur de l'aéroport de nice ainsi
que des experts juridiques et financiers
[Musique]
merci de votre présence et des amants
vont être connectés pour évoquer la
situation touristique et surtout le
roman et la préparation donc on attend
tous impatiemment dont les médias c'est
de sauver l'outil de travail est était
humainement ce qui affronte la crise ça
c'est l'immédiat ensuite il ya deux
autres temps il ya le temps delà de la
reprise de l'activité en période
d'épidémie aux logiques et de pandémie
et ensuite il y à l'après s'il existe
mais en tout cas avec les évolutions
structurelles qui ne dépendent pas
forcément à l'épidémie qui auraient été
accélérés pour les peelings et je vais
passer la parole à nathalie thomas qui
voulait ajouter des précisions et en
général à outils qui souhaitait aussi au
nom des restaurateurs mais trop tard
la crise est un accélérateur de
transformation c'est notre fils telle
qu'elle existait attendre ne va pas
pouvoir repartir sur les fondements sur
le même modèle économique et sur la
réorganisation
il faut mettre autour de la table tous
les intervenants et il faut faire c'est
d'abord un audit de la situation et il a
profité de prévention c'est gros c'est
dieu qui m'a permis de réaliser à ne
l'ont pas de la situation et ne le fasse
aux poudres et des ailes qui vont être
absorbées parce que bon on voit des gens
aujourd'hui des entreprises qui ont
absorbé leur précieux et qui se trouve à
l'est mosellan que ça c'est une
situation catastrophique à la fin pour
les dispenser d'entreprise pour le chef
d'entreprise uwe nittel et pour les
créanciers pour les packs de l'homme
le fragment à 40 donc un non 6 selon qui
les données très élevé
et avec les chiffres d'affaires ont
discuté de tout ça est ce que je ne veux
pas rater surtout que j'aborde dans
notre sujet riche et de qualité
malheureusement totalement et clairement
le cap
c'est le schéma qui gagne même il ya
parfaitement construit un coup c'est le
schéma historique de la ville alimentant
des loyers des charges crise on a pour
l'instant en ce qu'il chantait un nom
d'entreprise est clair vous verrez que
nous avons des plans de assez précis on
va travailler à nouveau avec expédia
avec lui et 7 cf des plans médias le
point du et en y mettra des moyens qu'il
faut pour faire gagner notre destination
qu'elle pourrait avoir une véritable
offensive en termes d'offre d'offres de
tourisme loisirs et d'offres de tourisme
d'affaires vont clés de la valeur de
créer de la valeur ajoutée et défendre
les emplois sur notre territoire
les édiles locaux ont fait leurs preuves
et aujourd'hui fort de propositions il
souhaite être au rendez-vous de la
relance les maires des grandes villes et
les prisons de métropole ne sont
aujourd'hui pas suffisamment associés au
dialogue et à la construction des plans
de relance les administration
centralisée ne venons pas ça dans leur
adn qu'à un moment il faut savoir
travailler avec et pour ça les
collectivités locales et notamment les
municipalités ont besoin d'être
davantage responsabilisés et elle le
souhaite
enfin moi j'aimerais que ça aille plus
loin dans tout vous dire j'aimerais
qu'on aille que les décisions elles
soient prises sur la base d'avis qu'ils
sont donnés avant être fois que la
machine est lancée
la réponse allait sans doute plus dans
une manière de faire confiance à
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux que dans
une nouvelle législation en matière de
décentralisation et on a une occasion
c'est celle de la relance décidé par
définition c'est tranché un plan de
relance c'est un moment dans lequel vous
prenez des décisions et des orientations
on est toujours dans une espèce
d'injonction totalement contradictoire
parce qu'il ya des gens qui disent il
faut qu'on soit associée mais c'est
écrit en tout petit si on fait pas
exactement ce qu'on dit on considérera
qu'on n'a pas été entendu être associés
c est associé à un processus de
réflexion
moi je ne prétends pas quand je prends
une décision que tout ce que j'associe à
ma décision se retrouveront dans la
décision nous représentons un des
leviers majeurs de l'investissement
public et nous savons que au moment de
cette crise économique et sociale qui va
durer il faut de véritables
levier pour relancer l'activité et y
compris donc favoriser la création
d'emplois la rénovation des bâtiments
faire que les passoires thermiques ne
soient plus des passoires thermiques
tout le secteur du recyclage des déchets
et de de la réparation ou de la durée
emploi et être quoi faire mais pas sans
les collectivités passons les maires
passant les régions passant les
départements
[Musique]
et quand il s'agit de défendre le coeur
stratégique de sa vie le maire de rouen
tape du poing sur la table dans cette
ville historiquement industriels c'est
un compte à rebours qui a commencé et ce
afin n'augure rien de bon
la chapelle darblay la dernière usine de
recyclage de papiers en france
elle traite les déchets papiers de 26
millions d'habitants une entreprise de
230 employés au coeur de l'économie
circulaire et si rien n'est fait elle
fermera ses portes en juin
sa vente a été freinée par la situation
économique imprévisible qui se
rejoignent sur d'abord le constat de la
surdité dans la plaine l'absurdité
absolue je le rappelle le 21ème siècle
ne sera pas n'est pas écologique
l'économie demain est aujourd'hui doit
être d'abord une économie circulaire six
chapelles d'arrêt n'est pas au coeur de
l'économie circulaire qu'il est
quelqu'un le démentir sur ce voyage
invite chez gilles demain bon c'est
fermé non non mais sérieusement si
j'appelle d'arbres les débats au coeur
de la puissance publique elle peut pas
tout mais elle peut faire des choses du
côté des collectivités
nous nous devons nous pouvons prendre
toute notre part pour faire quoi pour
faciliter financièrement au plan local
sept reprises y compris d'une façon
transitoire comme ça a été fait dans
d'autres sites et aussi pour dire aux
futurs repreneurs industriels
si vous reprenez le site en vous
garantis par exemple un minimum
d'approvisionnement en papier et c'est
intéressant pour les collectivités c'est
pas de la philanthropie en réalité
pourquoi parce que si vous n'avez pas
une papeterie qui recycle le papier
quand vous vous triez vos déchets à
paris à nantes war où vous voulez ils
vont où après ils vont en allemagne ils
vont en belgique
si vous croyez que le coût carbone de ce
type de recyclage et performante
non pas du tout soit vous avez trier
pour rien parce qu'à la fin il est brûlé
le papier où il est enfoui c'est ça
qu'on veut au 21e siècle on va brûler du
papier c'est absurde
on a besoin de l'engagement de la
puissance publique nationale à ce niveau
là parce que c'est un enjeu de filières
où l'avait dit en amont et en aval
c'est un enjeu de société donc nous
sommes vrai là aussi à nous engager
collectivement pour bien au moins sur
une base minimale sécuriser une partie
de la pression'' ans qui contribuera à
diminuer le risque est ce qu'ils sont
contribuera à faciliter la soutenabilité
en fait des projets plus de 70
maintenant maires de grandes villes
paris le havre nantes rennes saint denis
villeurbanne et j'en oublie bien au delà
de ma famille politique
vous dites à edouard philippe l'hidalgo
sont pas toujours ensemble et bien se
rejoignent pour dire il faut absolument
sauver cette usine pour des raisons
écologiques clairement pour des raisons
d'économie d'économie circulaire et
aussi pour des raisons économiques
publics et ont bien en tête qu'on est
dans une pandémie qui est l'une des
conséquences de nos atteintes répétées
et massive à la biodiversité
et ça c'est pas le maire de lyon qui
vous dis hein c'est le directeur de l'om
est ce qu'il a dit récemment
donc on a besoin d'accélérer la
transition écologique et je dirais même
que la prise de conscience les prises de
conscience induite par la crise
sanitaire vont nous permettre
d'accélérer
je vais vous donner juste un chiffre
l'accord de paris les engagements de
l'union européenne les engagements de la
france c'est moins 55 % des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pas dans son temps
d'ici 2030
c'est dans neuf ans 55% en neuf ans ça
veut dire 5 6% par an à la grosse donc
il faut porter ce cap
et puis encore une fois résisté résisté
parce que tous les jours faut résister
et les services qu'ils me disent ouais
bon ça serait moins cher si on achetait
des bus diesel
ah non c'est maintenant qu'on change
maintenant on achète plus de plus de bus
diesel arbres la crise et l'opportunité
de transformer nos systèmes et surtout
de réorienter notre économie dans les
territoires les maires sont prêts à se
saisir de ce défi peut-être le plus
important du 21e siècle
moi je suis pour qu'on investisse dans
l'activité économique locale bien
évidemment que la richesse elle puisse
rester là où elle est produite
moi mon objectif c'est pas d'engraisser
des actionnaires qui se trouve à
quelques dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres pour l'emploi que l'on créé
dans un entrepôt amazon
quand on laisse s'installer ces trois ou
quatre qui sont perdus en commerce de
proximité
donc c'est quoi le modèle économique on
veut jeff bezos sylla il
c'est quoi son lien avec ma ville il va
investir jeff bezos 6,6 à lyon j'en
doute et c'est un des vrais grands sinon
le principal défi de ce mandat
ce mandat qui est démarré dans la
tourmente de la crise sanitaire qui n'a
en rien effacer la crise écologique
on doit être capable de penser les deux
et c'est sans doute ce qui est assez
symptomatique on va dire d'une
une génération je suis pas si on peut la
qualifier nouvelle mais une génération
de femmes et d'hommes qui se sont
engagés dans la politique et notre
récemment et notamment dans l'écologie
si la situation sanitaire a révélé les
failles de notre système
elle a aussi accéléré les solutions
quand l'état gère l'urgence les
collectivités locales apportent une
réponse davantage centrée sur la
résilience en territoire des initiatives
sont déjà à l'oeuvre pour amplifier les
circuits courts et rendre nos systèmes
moins vulnérables bien avant le début de
la pandémie
la maire de rennes nathalie appéré avait
perçu cette nécessité d'initier des
mécanismes nouveaux alliant marchés
publics alimentation durable et
transition écologique
un pari gagnant et qui trouve tout son
sens à l'heure de la crise la crise a
montré à quel point l'accès à
l'alimentation était aussi une question
majeure est terre de source c'est un
mécanisme de marché public complètement
nouveau l'innovant il a fallu vaincre
quelques résistances juridique ou nous
garantissons aux agriculteurs qui
s'engagent à utiliser moins d'intrants
moins de pesticides des débouchés pour
leurs produits notamment dans la
restauration collective où nous venons
valoriser à la fois leurs biens leurs
produits les aliments qui sont consommés
mais aussi leur contribution à la
qualité de l'eau voilà l'exemple d'un
cercle vertueux dont l'organisation et
les objectifs politiques préexiste à la
crise sanitaire
mais dans les ambitions sont renforcées
la transition écologique et porte en
elle la relance économique puisqu'il
s'agit de faire évoluer un certain
nombre de secteurs pour pour aller vers
d'autres pratiques
j'ai vous prendre un exemple on a une
gastronomie fantastique à lyon on est la
ville de la gastronomie il va il
m'importe que nos restaurateurs mais je
vais pas leur imposer de main mais que
nos restaurateurs haye
de plus
en plus vers la valorisation de nos
produits locaux et même ultra locaux
mais c'est ça demain l'offre touristique
que l'on va présenter à lyon c'est avoir
une offre touristique qui soit
simplement compatible avec la planète
la fonction de maire a été mise à rude
épreuve ces dernières années une
fonction prenantes inspirante parfois
ingrate et pourtant la détermination de
nos élus restent intactes
[Musique]
le maire du plus petit village de la
plus grande ville
c'est celui vers lequel se tournent
celles et ceux qui ne savent plus vers
qui se tourner c'est pour moi la plus
belle des fonctions au sens où elle elle
m'oblige chaque jour à à être à la fois
aller coûte à penser de réponses
concrètes aux six militants politiques
avec engagement des ambitions de
transformation n'est pas là juste pour
gérer on veut transformer mais juste de
façon provisoire là pour être performant
tenté en tout cas au service des
habitants auxquels on appartient
on est dans une période de crise
sanitaire avec des gens sont malades
qu'ils s'ouvrent des gens qui meurent
avec des gens qui s'engagent tous les
jours pour sauver des vies être mère en
2021 c c'est à la fois soutenir et
donner envie on a beaucoup beaucoup de
chance d'être dans cette république
française et cette république française
à s'incarne aussi par sa démocratie
représentative et donc par ses élus et
donc par ces élus locaux donc c'est un
grand honneur
on les appelle les pompiers de la
république et pour cause à chaque site
ils sont en première ligne pour éteindre
l'incendié ils connaissent les
faiblesses de leur territoire et savent
activer leurs forces pour les corriger
en complétant les compétences de l'état
en palliant parfois à ses insuffisances
aujourd'hui plus que jamais leur mission
politique prend tout son sens
[Musique]